hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode whatsapp fels mit mir
luca mit wem auch sonst fangen wir
direkt an mit diesem wort fällt und zwar
schreibt eine person an seinen kumpel
nico die nachricht
meine jacke gilt gerade in der kerze der
antwortet nur ha ha und damit darf ich
euch herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
weiteren folge um seine wohl du musst
mir nachher mal bitte zehn euro für den
kasten bierlein bekommst du nächste
woche zurück ich hatte nur noch 15 euro
davon wollte ich mit neues make-up
kaufen damit ich hüpfe ich bin dafür war
das bier eigentlich gedacht ok das ist
ein dies auf einer ganz anderen ebene
bei diesem nächsten whatsapp viel
bekommt eine person von seiner mutter
die nachrichten geschickt bitte hör auf
das google logo dauernd zu verändern ich
mag das original gerne mama ich ändere
das logo nicht google macht das auf
meinem computer du entscheidest nicht
wie das google logo aussieht würde ich
das entscheiden würde ich wohl nicht so
ein klappriges altes auto fahren das ist
dann an der stelle auch wieder die
wahrheit hier schreibt ein vater seinem
sohn die nachricht bin gerade beim
einkaufen brauchst du noch irgendwas
park on wären gut gehe heute mit ein
paar heißen ladies aus schutz ist
wichtig mag ja dein gesicht ist schutz
genug
das war auch wieder sonntags auf einer
ganz anderen ebene alter wo bist du
suchen dich schon seit einer halben
stunde
falls es dir nicht aufgefallen ist ich
suche seit 15 minuten mit euch wusste
nur nicht wen wir suchen das könnte auch
sandra besoffen sein
mama holst du mich mal von der schule ab
wie versprochen mama mama ich werde
gerade überfallen mama ich habe jemand
erschossen
mama ich sterbe gerade kommst du mal
mama mein heißt dass sportlehrer ist ja
ok wartet bin gleich da und das ist
nicht meine mutter meine mutter war 30
minuten vor der vereinbarten uhrzeit da
und habe mich dann gefragt warum ich zu
spät wahr wird ein mädchen von einer
person namens simon gefragt hey könnte
ich dich mal was fragen wer bist du denn
nach simon von gestern der mit dem
dicken bizeps und sah der der nachher
noch eine weitere nummer von einer
anderen frau abgestaubt hat ja aber das
ist eine schlimme meinte ich soll mich
von ihr fernhalten irgendwo erkennt sie
dich wohl und sie meinte das wird nicht
gut ausgehen das war meine mutter
ja feiern jedes mal aufs neue die ganzen
sprachen lernen hier denkt eine person
dass sie diese nachricht an seinen
kumpel schreibt er schreibt diese
nachricht allerdings aus versehen eine
andere person allerdings lautet die
nachricht auf jeden fall die party ist
so der hammer kommen her scheiß egal was
du machst waldstraße 9
und warum schreibst du das jetzt seinem
klassenlehrer liebe grüße herr steiner
was war euer größter aus versehen an
eine andere nummer geschickt versteht
man das schreibt das wort in die
kommentare bei mir war es leider so dass
sich außer sie sind wirklich auch mal
einer lehrerin geschrieben habe die war
allerdings extrem cool ich habe zu einem
fifa spiel eingeladen und sich ist mit
nachnamen genauso wie man ja war
peinlich aber alles gut gegangen was
machst du eigentlich nach dem abi ich
mache den bachelor ökologie mit
anschließender fortbildung in touristik
und sag astrologie und was macht man
damit so witze die keiner versteht und
das ist die wahrheit richtigen nur im
bett und was machst du so ich hab mir
grad voll den fetten popel aus der nase
geholt
wieso schreibst du mir so eklige sachen
du hast doch angefangen
warum klatsche ich eigentlich immer
ja ich weiß ja auch nicht hier schreibt
ein typ seiner freundin mandy die
nachricht ich kommen einer stunde vorbei
und hole dich ab ok ja ich gehe mal ins
bad
bis später ich habe gerade geduscht und
jetzt finde ich meine nicht mehr
hahahaha bürste bürste haarbürste
ja wenn die ich würde dir tatsächlich
einen deutschkurs empfehlen bzw einfach
nur deshalb wieder auch die
autokorrektur ich glaube ich kann nicht
richtig reden hier schreibt eine person
seiner freundin petra hätscher ich habe
gerade eine stunde lang versucht
herauszufinden ob das licht am
kühlschrank auch ausgeht wenn die tür
zugeht omg hast du wieder gesoffen was
war das ergebnis nur ein bisschen es
geht aus ich habe mich rein gestellt
was
ist los mit einigen menschen hier bei
diesen nächsten chat verlauf zwischen
einer person namens manuell de zensiert
und der anderen person frage ich mich
auch gar nichts mehr und zwar schreibt
manuell asyl um 00 37 schreibt dann die
andere person wo seid ihr aber seid
falsch geschrieben wo ihr antwortet der
manuel der andere antwortet wo ihr
straße drin falsche zeit dann um 245
antwortet die person noch mal wo und
eine stunde später um 345 antwortet
manuell wo seid ihr das
ist so ein typischer
verlauf
mit sandra unterwegs ist und sie einfach
wieder irgendwann plötzlich abhaut und
sich verläuft papa ich hab ja heute
geburtstag ja mein sohn ich wünsche mir
ein buch zu meinem geburtstag ja ich
kaufe die alle bücher die du willst ein
sparbuch bitte ja so leicht können
kinder ihre eltern hoch nehmen das habe
ich tatsächlich auch mal gemacht und
zwar am nächsten woche veranstaltet
jemand einen grillen und fragt ganz
freundlich in der ortsgruppe wegen dem
grillen am wochenende ist jemand
vegetarier daraufhin antwortet petra ja
ich das ist ja voll lieb dass du fragst
petra roth aus der gruppe entfernt
ja
hey
hallo schatz habe ich dir eigentlich
schon mal gesagt die unglaublich gut
aussehend und toll du bist und wie sehr
ich dich liebe bitte sagt dass das auto
noch heil ist ja das ist so ein
typischer chat verlauf von mir und
meiner schwester früher beziehungsweise
nicht verlauf sondern eigentlich mehr
oder weniger die rede verlauf
beziehungsweise konversation weil wir
hatten früher noch keine richtigen
handys und wenn mir ein handy hatten
dann mussten die verdammt nochmal kurven
wenn wir im auto sagt hey wie gehts dir
ich bin der vom letzten freitag
wo war ich da und wer bist du ich weiß
nicht wo wir waren aber ich habe gerade
eine nummer in meiner boxershorts
gefunden alles klar dicker irgendwie
sind die hälfte dieser komplette
whatsapp fällt sehr einfach nur
entstanden wenn irgendwelche leute
betrunken waren
apropos betrunken soeben es eine neue
folge dick und doof von den podcast mir
online gegangen sandra hat die folge
bedruckten die war sehr voll während der
ein linkes ist in der beschreibung hier
bekommt eine person von seinem schatz
sie die nachricht ich freue mich auch
wenn die zwei wochen lehrgang vorbei
sind darauf antwortet er ich werde dich
vermissen weiß gar nicht wie ich das
ohne dich aushalten soll lässt du mir
deine da die riecht so gut nach dir
die kann ich abends mit ins bett nehmen
dann ist es ein bisschen so als wärst du
da
autokorrektur ich hätte gern
eine jacke
wer kennt nicht wenn man
ganz toll vermisst einfach mal nachdenkt
tragen damit man halt noch ein bisschen
den geruch von ihr hat hier schreibt ein
vater eine nachricht die eigentlich an
seine frau gehen sollte an seinen sohn
und zwar hallo schatz hast du schon die
löcher abgeholt falsches fenster papa
entschuldigung das ging an deine mutter
moment was meinst du nele unten mich ja
ja
[Musik]
stark wie der vater sich auch überhaupt
nicht rausreden der akzeptiert das
einfach das niemand sagt ja ihr seid ja
ihr seid die meint dass jetzt der
nächste bortfelder schreibt eine person
seinem kumpel ich bin mal gespannt wie
alles meinen geburtstag vergisst wieso
dann hast du dein geburtstag heute mein
gott da kann ich euch wieder eine story
zu raushauen als ich vor zwei jahren
noch studiert habe hatten ich und ein
kumpel von mir so in etwa den gleichen
weg zur uni und dann haben wir uns halt
immer morgens getroffen vom supermarkt
sind da zusammen die letzten 500 meter
zur uni gelaufen und dann haben wir halt
ich ganz gut unterhalten und in der uni
hat er dann von allen glückwünsche
entgegengenommen
zu seinem geburtstag und ich dachte mir
nur so ich bin 500 meter mit mit dem
ganz nah war unangenehm
beim nächsten whatsapp verwendet eine
mutter den gleichen trick an dem ihr zu
beginn dieser art fels folge schon
hatten uns vorschreibt sie ihrem sohn
geschirrspüler ausgeräumt hausaufgaben
erledigt patentante angerufen zimmer
gesagt papa und ich haben beschlossen
die nächsten monate ein auto zu kaufen
um einen plot wirklich danke nein wollte
nur wissen ob der nachrichtendienst das
sind irgendwie so taktiken von so eltern
apropos eltern der nächste mord
verhandelt auch von einer mutter wieder
und zwar schreibt eine person seiner
mutter mama ich muss dir was sagen ich
bin schwanger liebling bis zu betrunken
ja warum
ich denke nicht dass du schwanger bist
thomas
was schaue ich mir an und das frage ich
mich auch bei dieser nachricht und
verschreibt er eine person du hängst ich
kann es kaum abwarten dich endlich
wiederzusehen du bist so männlich deine
brustbehaarung macht mich ganz wild komm
endlich her
mama was geht ab das tut mir so
unendlich leid das war eigentlich für
dein vater gedacht du hast mir den
schock meines lebens verpasst ich glaube
ich somit besser eine eigene wohnung und
lasst euch euren spaß moment mal papa
hat doch gar keine brusthaare mama ja
das ist dann jetzt blöd für die mutter
der nächste whatsapp gehandelt
allerdings wieder von einer mutter
irgendwie ist die hälfte der ganzen welt
einfach nur entstanden wenn leute
betrunken waren und die andere hälfte
handelt von müttern allerdings gut es
geht um diese nachricht und zwar
schreibt die mutter alles es ist zehn
uhr wo bleibst du ich bin in einem
dunklen hinterhof in der südstadt und
versuche meinen dealer zu einem
mengenrabatt zu überreden
solange ich weiß wo du bist ja
ich habe mich gerade so oft versprochen
als ich das hier gelesen haben um 24
grad grad in köln nicht auf der terrasse
und ich glaube ich habe ich habe zehn
sonnenstiche kommen allerdings nun doch
schon zum letzten whatsapp
sms-nachrichten fail whatever für die
heute ja wieso uns war es dieser hier
wer ist der typ mit dem du redest habe
ich gerade kennengelernt weil sehen was
daraus wie jetzt na dann viel glück
und was ist los veni vidi violine das
heißt wenig wie die vicky nein war schon
richtig ich kam
ich sah mich vergeigte und das ist
leider mein liebesleben in einem bild an
der stelle ich das heute wieder ist
allerdings ob enten meine lieben freunde
wenn euch die heute mittlerweile schon
zehnte motzfeld folge gefallen hat das
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
wir das schaffen gibt 40.000 likes das
wäre geistes stabil
wer kennt es nicht wenn etwas einfach
geistes stabil ist wie bereits gesagt
wirklich mega interessieren was eure
krasseste nachricht war die aus versehen
die falsche person geschickt habt
schreibt mir das wie bereits gesagt gern
und in die kommentare und jetzt befinden
sich auch schon im auto meine liebe
freunde hier oben findet ihr ein 2d
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren das ist super
weil dann verpasst ihr sohn geistreichen
wie das heutige video einfach in zukunft
nicht mehr
also klickt da gern drauf oder klickt
hier drauf denn da ist ein weiteres
video verlinkt
schon könnte weil wir haben alle kt nix
zu tun